sir kristaps are you excited about your
new Lord Commander phys Dale looks like
House Knicks won't be getting rocked
anytime soon big man don't listen to it
crows are all liars contract well okay
not all crows I know a story about a
bird his name was Larry and his hair was
fair just like yours but he had a third
eye that could see into the future also
a bad back I hate your stories I know a
story about a child who hated stories I
also know a story about the Chris
child's who punched Kobey's I could tell
you about ser Ewing the sweaty those
were always your favorite does one of my
favorites I could tell you the tale of
star berry shagging in his wagon with
the marketing apprentice is this the
sort of salacious and flirtatious story
you like no maybe you'd like a scary
story I think you can scare me Walt
Clyde whatever your name is there is
nothing more frightening than being the
second option to Carmelo
in the Triangle oh my sweet Latvian
child what do you know about fair fair
is for the elders who suffered through
the entire reign of James Dolan
Fanning's are born and live and die or
without seeing a playoff win or a decent
draft pick it was in this darkness that
Isiah Thomas gave a five year contract
to Rome big snacks James pouf exactly
that is the time for fear my lanky Lord
watching Stephon Marbury Steve Francis
and Jamal Crawford three shoot first
guards try to coexist in the same
backcourt
traffic's busting in their cribs bloated
contracts for bloated players we
mean smothered their babies rather than
see them watch any curry get paid 60
million goateed freaking lemon cakes on
the bench and don't get me started with
Bargnani fear is the Lord Dolan gling
loot and having to tell him he's
wrestling and dancin when inside you're
crying and dying but you keep lying and
complying because it's terrifying
oh did I just hear Lord darling roll
rolling hello yes it is I Lord Olin just
wanted to stop and sing christop say a
little cheer up song oh how delightful
an affine descent a good place to cry
coolers we're not going to tank or play
Frank nil Akina
whose moody is a guy better find acept
a good place to pray for all your sins
will I overpay Trey Burke or let him
walk away like Jeremy Lin dancer and no
please do not welcome back maybe I'll
resign Jarrett Jack
hello pay the luxury tax to give Tyreke
Evans a max five-year contract I should
bring Isaiah Thomas back and the small
one too for a longer deal I think y'all
furred Peyton is the next Bradley Beal
all right Chris laps pours [ __ ] time
for you to hurry up and heal a little
birdie told me physically it's as
European big men talk to you later buddy
see you Lithuania where's Oh Cleo nakum
[Music]